افاد مراسل الجزيره بان قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي انتشرت بشكل كبير عند مداخل
البلده القديمه ومحيطها بالقدس المحتله
ومنعت عددا من الفلسطينيين من الوصول الى
المسجد الاقصى لتاديه صلاه الجمعه معنا من
باب الاسباط في القدس المحتله مراسل
الجزيره امين درغامي امين كيف تبدو هذه
الاجراءات الاسرائيليه في يوم
الجمعه
[موسيقى]
نعم هي اجراءات امنيه مشدده وانتشار واسع
لقوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي في محيط البلده
القديمه وايضا على طول اسوار وبوابات
البلده
القديمه هناك اعاقه واضحه
للمصلين قبي انطلاق صلاه الجمعه
بتشديد اجراءات التفتيش ومنع كما ك ترون
هنا منع
لدخول الفئه عموريه محدده حتى الان الجيش
الاسرائيلي لم يحدد من يحق له الدخول ومن
لا يستطيع الدخول هم
فقط يدخلون من يرغبون او من يريدون
ويمنعون
ايضا من يريدون هناك ايضا انتشار واسع
حول المسجد الاقصى هناك اجراءات تفتيش
مشدده وق ل الطرقات اضافه الى النشر
ل الامن بالاضافه الى الخياله في باب
العمود
هذا الباب المجاور طبعا لباب الاسباط
المؤدي الى البلده القديمه
وايضا الى المسجد الاقصى طبعا كانت الجمعه
الماضيه قد شهدت تاديه الصلاه من قبل
13000 مصل في رقم غير مسبوق
منذ السابع من اكتوبر الماضي الى ان قوات
الاحتلال عادت هذا الاسبوع لتشدد
الاجراءات وتمنع المصلين من الدخول وتاديه
ص الاص امين درغامي مراسلنا شكرا جزيلا
لك